[Music]
all right hi everyone good afternoon so
my name is Phoebe bionis and I am
assistant professor of industrial
engineering and computer science at USC
and also associate director of the
Center for in society at USC and on
behalf of my team I would like to
present the problem that we have
identified in the context of AI and
public health it's the problem of using
AI to prevent VL so as Rishabh presented
yesterday VL is a huge public health
problem in fact it's the second largest
parasitic killer in the entire world
after malaria every year there's about
200,000 infections and 70% of those
cases actually of the cases that occur
in India occur in Bihar and U P there is
a treatment that's available for
treating the VL but unfortunately it's
not widely available it's not easily
accessible the way that VL spreads is
actually by means of these hand flies
which can carry the disease and and can
infect you there is a way of preventing
VL which is by this indoor residual
spraying is a spray that we go and place
indoors inside houses and can
effectively eradicate the Flies and so
prevent the spread of the disease the
way this is performed is basically twice
yearly before and after the monsoon
season unfortunately though what happens
is that we need to have health workers
that actually go and do the spraying and
the number of health workers that we
have at our disposal amount of spray
that we have at our disposal are both
limited and also the spring needs to
occur in a particular time window in the
year and so we have also a time
constraint a I can actually help address
this problem in particular the way in
which we can view this problem what we
need to do is we have a finite number of
health workers that can start at a
particular
village in India and can for each health
worker we can decide which cities they
will visit and the sequence in which
they will visit these cities these
villages so this is a vehicle routing
problem whenever a public health worker
visits a particular village they can
conduct the spring and we can decide the
intensity of the spraying and depending
on the intensity we will eradicate a
certain proportion of the Flies which in
turn will prevent a certain portion of
the disease from spreading we have some
data already available at our disposal
to help inform this decision making
problem these are basically patient
level data so we have for both Bihar and
GP historical cases so we can figure out
when and where a particular individual
was affected by VL I understand that
these people are also tracked in the
system so we can know whether they were
cured for each weekend we also have
information about areas that were
actually sprayed in the past we have a
patient level data demographic
information and so on and we also have
elements that can help that actually
impact the efficacy of the spring such
as cleanliness of the households the
status of the village etc apparently if
say your house is not so clean then the
efficacy of the of the spraying will
drop we believe that there's some
additional data that we could collect
that could help inform our
decision-making even better in
particular deaths due to VL so this
would be cases that have not been
reported at the time when they occur but
that resulted in the death and also
additional data that can help us
understand maybe what other factors
could affect the efficacy of the spring
like weather conditions and things like
that what we propose to do is to take
this historical data that we have at our
disposal
I like historical cases of VL whether
the treatment was success
soon weather data etc to train certain
machine learning models that will help
us understand where we will strike in
the current year that will help us also
understand the effectiveness and the
efficacy of a particular spraying
strategy we will use that information
then to inform to feed into an
optimization model that would actually
generate these these routes for each and
every health worker we're gonna we
believe that this approach is very
promising in particular we believe that
by using this data-driven optimization
approach I will be able to improve both
the efficacy and effectiveness of this
field prevention strategy we envisage
some possible and non technical
roadblocks that we may face in
particular our proposed approach because
it will be implemented actually by the
government it does require government
buying but fortunately our eShop does
have contact with policy makers in the
area so we're crossing our fingers some
additional challenges relate to dropout
rates of these health workers it seemed
that every year some of them dropped out
in which case you may need to
unexpectedly have to retrain health
workers to to teach them how they can do
the spring there are some ethical
concerns in particular so we have these
basically scarce resources that were
seeking to decide how to allocate if we
allocate them someplace and not
somewhere else were effectively deciding
who to treat and who not to treat like
who who may get the disease and who
won't this is a very serious in my view
ethical concern and how can we somehow
tackle it is maybe not clear we have of
course privacy concerns related to the
fact that we will be using a patient
level data and location like address
information etc and the higher level of
course we are
when can I think about other health
priorities
to address before this one and so some
concrete next steps some milestones that
we would like to reach in the next year
I guess we we believe that we can at
least all the technical parts of the
project within this coming year first of
all we would investigate whether these
additional sources of data that we
believe would be helpful are actually
available to us the second step which we
can start after the first few months of
getting started with the project would
be actually this machine learning step
of doing these predictions of a
predicting hot spots and effectiveness
of spraying etc and the last step would
be actually the optimizations that I
forgot to mention this is actually a
relatively large scale problem because
there's actually a thousand possible
villages that we could be we could be
where we could be spraying giving routes
to shoot a number of possible routes
further for the health workers so we
would have to do some work on
scalability at least if successful and
this AI based a prevention approach I
would be deployed by the government we
don't think that there is a need for a
particularly fancy like application to
share the route instead this can be
shared by just a simple text message or
paper based transmission we have
identified two strategies for evaluating
the impact of our proposed approach
first of all we can go back and track
now the decrease hopefully in the new
cases of VL for that given year and then
we can hopefully also showcase that
maybe we're able to increase the number
of houses that actually were spread is
great all right this is it thank you
very much for your time and attention
[Applause]
all right can you can you just train
everyone to spray their own house so you
would still have I guess to get to them
the product so even if they knew how to
spray they need to have the tools and
the and the chemicals needed to spray so
you'd have a similar kind of routing
problem right you need to go and drop
this off but maybe actually when
actually now that I think about it it's
maybe a good idea because you can always
go and do it earlier so now you don't
have this time
[Music]
and I guess why these drops the time
constraint you maybe you need more to
eat right you need the equipment as well
to spray which would be more costly so
and we do have limitations in the amount
of products what's available as well